Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and hopefully
by now you’ve seen the Deadpool comic con
trailer.
What happened was a high def version of test
footage was leaked by the people that made
the footage.
Fox commissioned them to do a test for a Deadpool
movie back in 2011.
So that footage was what you were watching
if you saw it.
This video is going to be a breakdown of what
that whole thing was about and what’s going
on with the Deadpool movie right now.
A couple of big people close to the project
are doing a fun experiment.
In case you’re just finding me for the first
time I do Marvel and DC videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So starting with the leaked footage.
Here’s the real story:
Blur Studios is the effects house that made
the trailer.
They are the ones that posted it the week
before comic con.
It was done without Fox’s knowledge, Fox
had nothing to do with it and right after
it posted the video was taken down.
Then people reuploaded it and it got taken
down again, rinse and repeat.
The trailer wasn’t part of a Fox Panel or
anything.
It was just the people behind the film trying
to get Fox to see that there was demand for
it.
Even though the Test Footage is from 2011,
FOX still hasn’t given the movie a greenlight.
The trailer itself features Ryan Reynolds
voicing the character and presumably he’s
still down to play the role if the movie ever
happens.
Here’s some background on where the movie
is:
There is a finished script.
It was written by Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick.
Ryan Reynolds along with all the other people
who have read it say it’s great.
Up at the top, Lauren Schuler Donner and fellow
producer Simon Kinberg are open to the idea
of a Deadpool movie but the belief is that
other people at Fox are hesitant to make an
R-Rated Comic Book movie.
I feel like we can all agree that a Deadpool
movie would have to be a hard-R in order to
be taken seriously.
The source material isn’t like anything
we’ve seen recently and that’s part of
the reason why we haven’t heard anything
new about the movie.
For example, Guardians of the Galaxy is a
movie about a bunch of assholes being ridiculous
and funny and violent.
But Deadpool is a cold-blooded killer, it’s
in the name.
His body count would be higher than a zombie
apocalypse movie.
Right now, the comic book movie culture is
tuned for family friendly stories.
The closest example of a hard R marvel film
is the last Punisher film, War Zone.
Any time you walk into an office at FOX and
ask for 70 Million dollars to make an R-Rated
comic book movie, all they have to do is point
at Punisher and say “it’s not going to
work”.
Nobody wants to make a movie that isn’t
guaranteed to earn a billion dollars.
How do you make a Deadpool movie that earns
a billion dollars?
There are a couple of options.
Mostly, you tune it down to PG 13 so you can
market it to a bigger audience.
Also, foreign markets like China have very
strict rules about violence in films.
If you can get a movie released in China,
that’s an extra 100 million dollars you
could potentially make.
That’s why Transformers put so many Chinese
things in their movie.
So the Chinese government would release it.
The government controls which movies get released
there.
It’s crazy I know.
But all most studios care about is making
money.
Which is where we get to the creators and
the Deadpool Experiment that’s happening
right now.
Right now on twitter Rhett Reese, the guy
who wrote the script started an experiment
to see who would buy a ticket for an R-Rated
Deadpool movie.
Even Rob Liefeld, the artist on the Deadpool
comic book jumped on board.
It just started but I’ll post a link in
the description if you guys want to participate.
He’s just asking you to retweet his tweet
as a way to show FOX people really are interested
in a Deadpool movie.
I know a lot of you guys are asking why don’t
they just do a Kickstarter?
If fans want it bad enough, they’ll fund
it themselves.
The reason they can’t do that is FOX owns
the rights, so the only way the filmmakers
could kickstart a Deadpool movie would be
if FOX said okay.
And they haven’t, so no kickstarter.
I haven’t read the script, but here are
my top picks for stories I think they should
do:
At the top is Joe Kelley’s run.
It’s collected in an omnibus if you guys
haven’t read it yet, his run started in
1997.
He’s the one that gave Deadpool all the
signature character traits you see in the
current comics.
Start to finish it was one of the best collections
of Deadpool stories ever.
Most of the Deadpool pictures you see people
posting come from this run.
After that there’s Deadpool’s time on
X-Force.
It’s Rick Remender’s run on Uncanny X-Force.
It’s collected in an omnibus too in case
you guys want to read it all.
It started in 2010 with Uncanny X-Force Number
1 and went to issue 35.
There is an X-Force movie in development at
Fox, so even if they don’t give Deadpool
a solo movie, they could make him a member
of X-Force or at least a part of the movie
if he’s not a part of the team.
Usually when people make new team-based comic
book movies they keep it really simple.
Like X-Men started with a small cast and then
expanded.
So I’m not expecting Fox to jam Deadpool
into their first X-Force movie.
But he could cameo like he did in Wolverine
Origins.
After those two runs, I think Merc With A
Mouth would make for a great movie.
That was Deadpool in the Savage Land.
Picture him walking around with his decaying
severed head that he talks too.
That might be a little much to expect from
a movie, but I’d love to see them include
the talking head as an easter egg.
They kind of did that in the Wolverine Origins
movie but it’s not about him just talking
to a severed head.
The head has to look like he’s been carrying
it around all year.
Super gross but not quite a skeleton.
Let me know if you guys would rather see Ryan
Reynolds come back or if you want to see someone
new.
His career has kind of hit a speedbump recently
so this seems like the kind of project he
would jump on just because it’s high profile.
I’d really like to see somebody new come
in.
Zachary Quinto did a great job of playing
a crazy supervillain on Heroes even if that
show lost some steam, Jonathan Rhys-Meyers
is another person who’s great at playing
crazy people.
I don’t picture deadpool with a british
accent and if you saw Dracula Season 1, I
hated his fake american accent.
But he’s another strong choice.
If Jeremy Renner weren’t already Hawkeye
I would add him to my Deadpool list.
Interesting side note: there was actually
an awesome Deadpool vs Hawkeye storyline in
the comics during Dark Reign.
Sam Worthington would have to go a little
over the top but he has the right physique
for it.
And I could maybe get on board with Tom Hardy.
I’m looking forward to seeing him in Mad
Max fury road.
I think he’d have a harder time selling
the comedic aspects of Deadpool, but I think
he could do it.
But let me know which other actors you think
would make good Deadpool’s.
As of right now I don’t think we’ll see
an actual Deadpool movie until after X-Force.
And that movie won’t get here till well
after X-Men Apocalypse.
They are working on a new Old Man Logan Wolverine
solo movie for Hugh Jackman so expect that
to come before Deadpool too.
I think those movies are the real reason FOX
isn’t rushing into Deadpool.
They feel like they have the X-Men and Wolverine
movie formula down.
They can make those movies and guarantee a
big profit.
So they don’t have to scramble for new franchises.
So in related news, Since all of you guys
voted for it I’ll be doing new Doctor Who
and Legend of Korra next.
I’ll try to have all of that stuff up by
Saturday morning but you can follow me on
twitter and facebook for updates.
Links to all that at the bottom of the description.
Right now click here for a breakdown of all
the DC Comics movies coming after Batman vs
Superman and click here to learn all about
Guardians of The Galaxy 2.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!